hey everybody this is jeff posnick from
the youtube developer relations team and
today we're going to cover a topic
that's a particular interest to folks
who are going to be migrating from the
older YouTube data API version 1 or
version 2 to the newer YouTube data API
version 3 we certainly encourage
everybody to start that migration
process if they haven't done so yet and
the topic we're going to cover right now
involves registering for an API key to
use with version 3 of the API this is
something that all developers will need
to do either registering for an API key
to do read-only access to the data API
or registering for an OAuth 2 credential
if they're going to make readwrite
access calls we've have some other shows
that we could include a reference to if
you look at an annotation down there at
the bottom for registering for an oauth2
identity but we want to talk about how
you could actually register for a simple
read-only browser key right now
unlike version 2 of the data API there
are no more anonymous API calls so even
if you're doing something simple like
getting information about a video or
getting all the uploads in a specific
users channel you do need to register
first
fortunately the the registration process
is quite lightweight and you can do it
using the Google developers console so
let's switch to the screen sharing right
now and I'll walk you through the
process so we get here right now by
going to cloud Google com slash console
and it takes you to the screen
assuming you're already logged in to
your Google account I have a few
projects that already existed chat in
this account but let me just click the
create project button to walk through
the initial process for everybody I'm
going to call this YouTube API project
and you don't have to worry too much
about the project ID just leave it at
its default click create
and very shortly I will have a new
project with which I could then go and
enable the YouTube data API which is the
next step in the process so get my
welcome not sure what to do next I am
sure I want to go to the API is an auth
section over here on the left hand side
and I'm going to scroll down to the
bottom and look for the YouTube data API
version 3 if you did want to use the
analytics API also you could enable it
at this time but I'm just going to click
the off button to toggle that's to on
for the data API and if I scroll back up
here I'll see that it's now on so that's
great so with this developer's council
registration I can now use the data API
but I need one more piece of information
in order to start making those read-only
API calls and that's the API key and I
can do that by clicking on the
credentials section over here and going
to the public API access and clicking on
create new key so let's say
hypothetically that I'm going to be
doing these calls from the context of a
web browser making some JavaScript calls
in that case clicking on browser key is
appropriate if you're going to be doing
these read-only calls
mute from some sort of you know some
more server-side scripts you could click
on server key I have the option here of
making it so that the API key can only
be used when the JavaScript origin is a
specific whitelisted domain this is a
security feature way of protecting your
key a little bit it's not something I'm
particularly worried about right now but
you can fill in the actual domain for
your website if you would like to so I'm
just going to skip that and click create
and you'll see over here I have an API
key and information about any refer
being allowed because I didn't put any
restriction over there and this is an
API key that I could then use to make v3
API read-only calls so hopefully that
helps folks get started with a very
basics and stay tuned for more videos in
the series for moving from v2 the API to
v3 cheers everybody